So today we've talked about scripts, a complex way of understanding stories in
the natural world. Stories aren't just narratives, though.
Painting, songs, buildings are all stories of different kinds.
Stories are around us every single day. We started off by defining scripts.
Scripts are causally coherent series of events. They give a prototype for
what to expect in certain situations. The form of
the general script shows us the form of the overall prototype for the situation.
A specific instantiation of the script then specifies the content. Scripts can
have different tracks as well. At a high level, any kind of restaurant involves
entering, ordering, paying, and leaving. More narrowly though, fast food and
drive through restaurants involve different scripts from casual or
formal dining. This concludes our unit on common sense reasoning, but
note that some of what we cover in the future will be applicable to learning,
differentiating, and refining scripts.